c'est la pause puis leur permet de
lâcher leur fou avec concentré puis
dehors des eaux collection n'est pas de
travailler sortir courir jouer crier ou
bavarder
c'est indispensable pour les enfants du
primaire c'est prouvé qu'un enfant qui
bouge de façon régulière dans sa journée
va être beaucoup plus concentrés en
classe et les problématiques de
comportements vont diminuer
si on permet aux enfants d'être actif et
d'avoir un moment de pause et détente
rien dans le régime pédagogique du
québec n'indiquait jusqu'à aujourd'hui
la durée des pauses qui doivent être
accordés aux élèves du primaire pour que
les enfants profitent de minimum j'ai
dit d'un minimum de 20 minutes de
récréation le matin et l'après midi et
ce dès la prochaine rentrée scolaire
rousseau corée parce que c'est vrai que
ça va les aider à se calmer puis avait à
se dépenser un petit peu plus la
majorité des écoles de la commission
scolaire de montréal à cordes du
recreation de 15 minutes tous les jours
mais pour augmenter à 20 minutes chaque
récréation
ce sera plus compliqué qu'on pense
estime ce directeur d'école
les surveillants au recreation sur sur
les enseignants les enseignants s'ils
surveille dix minutes de plus par jour
scène un impact sur leur tâche
donc les tâches comme vous le savez
c'est conventionnelle la grandeur du
québec donc c'est pas vrai que ça va
être fait comme ça en claquant des
doigts parce qu'on va retirer dix
minutes de temps d'enseignement par jour
pour offrir dix minutes de plus de
récréation peut-être en tout cas moi je
le souhaite sinon on joue avec les
horaires et c'est plutôt compliqué une
école sur cinq au québec offrent une
seule récréation par jour
c'est le cas des écoles de la commission
scolaire de laval où il faudra ajouter
une autre période de récréation il y
aura des coûts aucun coup ça entre dans
la tâche des enseignants sur une
répartition différente du temps présent
s'élève c'est sûr que 20 minutes c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a beaucoup plus
de temps de jouer à l'extérieur quand on
sait que juste s'habiller ça prend un
peu tendre le visage la récréation va
changer quand les cours sont glacés mais
même quand il fait très froid sortir
cinq minutes à l'extérieur peut faire un
immense baie une pause qui permet
d'apprendre plus vite selon une
expérience haute et xav
où les élèves avaient profité de cinq
minutes de récréation toutes les heures
il faut dire que la logistique
vestimentaire il est beaucoup moins
compliquée qu'au québec ici anne louise
despatie radio canada montréal